(musique rock)
- Aux non-initiés, elles
sentiment de vertige. Mais ces
pentes de saut s s s ski font la
fierté de Courchevel en Savoie,
d'autant qu'elles sont rares.
maire de Courchevel
- Paèèèèèrement pour les Jeux
olympiques, ça a toujours été
quelque chose de très coûteux.
Et après, les communes qui
organisaient ou les stations qui
organisaient les compétitions
ne pouvaient pas les entretenir
et c'est... tombé.
- Mais pas ici.
30 ans aleleleleles Jeux olympis
d'Albertville, les olympiens
en herbe peuvent toujours
s'y entraîner et compétitionner.
- Vous savez, une station
atatatatation comme celle de
Courchevel, elle se doit d'avoir
des équipements comme ça.
On a plein d'équipements. Plein
d'équipements. On a construit
un stade de slalom éclairé pour
prendre des coupes du monde.
- Tout ça donne à Courchevel
une image sportive que le maire
préfère de loin à celle,
peut-être encore plus répandue,
de haut lieu de loisirs
d'archiluxe.
Au-delà des installations
sportives, les Jeux olympiques
d'Albertville ont surtout été un
tremplin qui a permis à la ville
et à toute la région de faire
un bond de 20 ans en avant
dans le développement
de ses infrastructures.nenenene,
la gare de TGV; ça semble
aujourd'hui banal.
Mais sans les Jeux en 1992,
la région n'aurait p
autant dans ses transports.
FRÉDÉRIC BURNIER FRAMBORET,
maire d'Albertville
- Ça a vraiment façonné
Albertville. Et c'est
aujourd'hui pour cela
qu'Albertville, entre
guillemets, est connue de façon
narerererererere internationale
puisque c'est vraiment les Jeux
qui ont fait exploser
cette ville.
- Une ville qui a su moderniser
son économie au passage,
dit le maire, mais qui doit
faire attention de ne pas
sombrer dans la nostalgie.Et ça.
- On peut dire que
c'est un cadeau empoisonné
parce qu'effectivement,
il y a un coût.ununununununun
investissement et c'est comme,
entre guillemets, la culture,
c'est-à-dire on y met de
l'argent, c'est pas parce que
c'est à perte, c'est juste que
c'est un investissement dans
la culture ou dans le sport.
Et c'est comme ça qu'il fautese,
et non pas comme une dette.
- Seul grand témoin physique du
passage des les Jeux olympiques
dans la ville qui leur a d
son nom, il a fallu investir
13 millions d'euros, soit plus
de 20 millions $ pour moderniser
la grande Halle Olympique.
OLIVIER JOLY, di
Halle Olympique d'Albertville
- Je pense que ce serait
terrible d'avoir un outil
qui soit à l'abandon après
les Je O O O O O O O On apporte
des prestations, plusieurs
offres à nos habitants, comme
la patinoire, le mur d'escalade,
des événements, une salle de
avavavavavavavavec des événemens
sportifs, culturels et
économiques.
- Les sites répartis dans toute
la Savoie qui ont accueilli
les athlètes de la planète
entière pour quelque 23 jours
sont presque tous encore
aujourd'hui en activité. Et
s'ils contribuent tous à l'ess
économique de la région, ils
continuent aussi de bénéficier
d'argent public pour rester
au sommet de leur discipline.
(musique rock)
1,5 km, 19 virages;
c'est ce qui attend aujourd'hui
près de 12 000 visiteurs chaque
année en quête de sensations
fortes qui passent p
de bobsleigh à La Plagne.
BRUNO THOMAS, DG, Piste
olympique de bobsleigh La Plagne
- On reçoit aujourd'hui
des clients qui viennent
tout sim
sur la piste olympique des Jeux
olympiques d'Albertville
et parcourent la même piste,
les mêmes virages, évidemment un
tetetetetetetetetete puisqu'on a
trois produits qui vont
de 80-85 km/h jusqu'à 120 km/h
pour les plus sportifs
ou ceux qui sont en rechercheti.
- Rassurez-vous : aucun besoin
d'une expérience ou d'un talente
et apprécier la petite minute
et demie que dure la descente.
Dès le lendemain des Jeux,
les équipements de La Plagne
ont été complètement transformés
pour permettre des
automatisées, une première
dans le monde.
- Les premiers critères étaient
d'avoir un engin qui soit
autoguidé, autofreiné,
où un client embarque et soit
complètement, on va dire,
a la découverte d'une activité
sans une obligation que ce soit
de piloter ou d'accélérer
ou de freiner.
- Les Jeux d'Albertville
ont laissé dans leur sillage
cerererererererererererere de
l'événement. Et pourquoi pas,
demande-t-on ici, se relancer
dans l'aventure olympique?
- Aujourd'hui, on a pratiquement
tous les équipements qu'il faut.
On n'est pas obligés de
reconstruire des tremplins,asase
reconstruire une piste de bob.
Tous ces équipements qui coûtent
très, très cher, on les a.
Nos stades sont très bienuiuiui.
- Horizon Albertville 2030?
La région est bien en pist